die kommune kann nämlich die nzz bei mir
dass karten kommen jetzt machen aber ich
habe auch einige sätze ich meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen zu einem neuen team battle und
zwar bei dem app store und wir müssen
bei dieser map bitte also der die das
ziel ist wir sind in dreierteams ronny
kd den amc und contra hd spielen hier
alle zusammen in einem team und wir
müssen gegen drei andere leute einen
kern von denen auf einer map zerstören
das heißt abbauen
eine luft explodieren lassen oder
ähnliches und ja wir werden das gewinnen
dass es unsere taktik und der henry ist
mit uns in skype der getrennt jetzt
gleich alle staaten irgendwie ich weiß
nicht ganz los legen also unsere taktik
eigentlich folgendermaßen es gibt zwei
inseln wie auf der alten die gegner auf
der anderen und dann neben ersten kisten
aus der stadt aus der stadt ist unsere
sachen einer geht direkt auf angriff die
anderen warten rüsten sich aus und dann
muss der welt auf angriff was mein
fertig ich bin hinten den er geht auf
angriff erst mal auf sachen holen
ich würde heute die jump und dann geht
dahin ja immer sofort die geile rüstung
voltaire ex brauchen wir dass vielmehr
die das verteidigen den 18 jahre hast
recht ich hoffe jetzt gibt's rangnick
nicht alles erreicht so einfach ist und
ich habe nur noch lose bekommen herzlich
euro bisher noch nie haben uns nämlich
ganz schön sehen das laufen normale
rüstung musste ich noch mal länger hier
hier hier hier der
bist du deiner lauf doch man weil ich
hab' ich hab die porsche nicht alter
leute mir doch gegeben wolltest du fan
ist dass ich zur onic luftgeist ich
glaube ja als sonic läuft den als
verpackt ich hab's nicht weiter an dem
gehweg also im wald hier hessen wahl
zwischen beiden basen und hier soll ist
so angeblich irgendwo paar coole sachen
geben ob das der fall ist wissen
natürlich dass als ob man das darf man
ich hätte besser wissen wir hier kommt
jetzt kommt der narr oder nicht egal ob
ich habe immer wegfliegen der mitte
plötzlich wieder so unsichtbar in check
soll weg gehen
also ich sehe deren basis aber aber ich
bin hier auf dem eigentlich fast ganz
oben auf dem baum aber hier ist gar
nicht drauf
er hat jedoch gesagt oben und mal wurden
alle guten bekommen wenn ihr begrüßung
habt dann kommt und helft mir ja ich
muss doch verteidigt
ich hab's eps habe ich das bringt doch
gar nicht wir können damit unsere basis
um zwischen ausstatten
das alles 3 da ist jemand den killig
bringt nichts man zu können obwohl doch
haben sie weniger sachen
ich warte gerade das international zum
kern soll das ist noch nicht geschlossen
das zeigt wie ich habe irgendwie voll
dem [ __ ] job oder ich lasse die ganze
zeit hinten aufpassen welche dollar
vorne obwohl die rüstung komm her ich
hab bogen für dich jetzt nach hinten
du kannst ja nicht in alle bereiche kann
nicht reporten glück habt dann danach
warte drückt den knopf dann nämlich
teleporter hier und ich hab ich genau
dieser telekommunikation bit andrea
teleportiert ich drücke gerade da einer
von ihr ist tot
wir müssen nur aufpassen der einzige weg
von den es eigentlich über diese brücke
zu uns oder oder kann man das kaum noch
hinten kam auch noch laufend eines
trends erkennt wie sehr hier den ersten
blick also privat so jetzt drauf leute
restlichen hallo kann müssen wir da
durch die luke dahinter ist am 1 juni
geht über die über die locker über die
luca luka über hier ja was euch dann
mache ich bin ganz langsam und ich sehe
alles spart das kleines ding
ich weiß nicht was klappt und ich hab
einen run zu überbauen luca ich weiß
nicht ich glaube ich sehe was soll ich
mich einfach einfach hinten geht auch
hin ich habe die tnt ist bei uns an der
schule schon bin ich bin dort zu hause
keine panik schuldiger sachen das macht
bei uns lena dann passau versprechen
dass jetzt in der luft von ikea weg ok
hast du touristiker dass die beschlüsse
er hält er steht da oben drauf der
wirtschaft setzen haben ich hatte
zahllose ich hatte viele sachen ratings
nicht mal so mal so folgte eigentlich
alle sachen wieder alles ok soll ich
herkommen soll hier bald nach dem guten
boden komplett ja ich habe mit sehr
guten boden ich habe einen anspruch
fahrenschon 23.12 ich will dort sitzt
das richtig jaja angriff ganz kurz leben
auf raten bis video bogen ehe das im
bogen darf den bogen medium nicht gar
nicht ob ich noch mal abwarten aber
diesmal auch keine sachen oder weil die
sind eigentlich alle da also ich bin
jeden moment da könnt mich botton partei
erwarte meine sachen die waren irgendwo
ja ich hab sie kommen sie kommen sie
trennt geweckt
ich bin wieder mit diesem thema ich hab
auch noch sachen für dich ich bin wieder
tod jedoch nicht kommentieren doch
hierhin stück nach hinten da siehst du
mich ja hallo hier kommen hier hin zu
sein
die können dich da treffen ich bin
direkt in den bau machbar so marsh risk
no fun machen und euch alle meine sachen
geben einfach mit tnt hinlaufen ja da
kommt dann so wenig hier hier hier hier
hier lass einfach mein komplettes
training mein leben einen schaden ein
ganz nicht töten
den kompletten nicht telepathe mich
ziemlich schnell an die community health
trend bei mir das klappen kommen jetzt
machen aber ich habe auch ein tt gesetzt
es ist auch noch da ist auch noch ein
kleiner alter form steht ihr denn auf
alle einmal auf einmal alle die nicht
auf andere ich wusste ich das feuer zwei
ganz normal schaden machen können damals
viele monster dem wald
warum macht ihr spinne ein halbherziger
cashflow ich baue jetzt alltag wirklich
dem rand entlang uns durch ihre basis
ganz daheim abzubauen
ich gehe auch schon gerade am rand
entlang ganz rechts wobei ich glaube da
gibt's auch umweg einer gelegt dass kein
weg den ich auch schnell gesagt aber
kannte man könnte sich rüber bauen wenn
man sich sachen holt oder wir können
übrigens auch mit dem tnt kümmern eine
falle bauen bei uns damit sie nicht wenn
sie reinkommen
ja ich meine so leiche tritt voller
reichtum inzwischen dritten woche wasser
oder wert unsere wort kommen die idee
kommen die kommen hallo janotta bottles
ich wollte
hier habe ich den gegner kommen gegner
kommen ja ja passt ja auch ich will oder
ich bin ausgerüstet ja den aber gut
schlecht hier ist wasser wie macht man
die pforten
nein ich bin in unserer basis
ich bin der basis ori dann kann ich nix
tun gerade vergiftet sich ausgeloggt die
gegen dafür erstellte auslöser für
server komm rein
ich bin hier und ich bin tot kratzt das
ging schnell
aber ich kriege meine sachen wieder wenn
ich mich nicht ganz bei dir ich hab
meine sachen wieder trotzdem kaka l
ich kann da unser land ist ja wohl eine
wurf trank sind jetzt bei uns oder wie
ja nein hier ist keine simple linke
macht heißt ich habe noch eine szene des
films stunden da gar nichts habe ich
getroffen
obwohl sie blind fahren schnell den
bevor dass wir unsere sachen einsammeln
ja ich komme gleich auch gar nicht kennt
erstmal thomas braun alter die schießt
einfach nur für sachen wie schnell geht
unsere sachen ich wenig sagen wir zu
neuen pass auf sie kommt direktions ich
hab' ich habe gar nichts war es würde
mich sofort treffen
fucking da gibt es doch feuer resistenz
tränke oder nicht eigentlich gibt es ist
einfach anders angehen würde ich sagen
okay
hauptsache einer von euch läuft um einen
trank rein ich habe gar nichts mit den
angreifen kann ja ich hab gar kein
schwert oder so soll ich einfach zu den
hinlaufen mit seinem komischen
politischen aufwind walking ist manchmal
probier's einfach ihr beide müsste es
aber gut verteidigen ist einer weniger
dann alter das ist doch ganz schnell und
kann richtig und kann hochspringen
versuche einfach darüber zu gehen jetzt
nein es geht gar nicht einfach ablehnen
wie kann es denn sein dass das der eine
von den immer eine diamant rüstung hat
und alles ich habe magath aus der map
gekickt glaube ich hab ihn getötet
nein ich halte aber gutes geld das jetzt
gehabt haben jetzt schon verloren
gericht jan ein die die hat der andrä ag
aufgesammelt öfter wieder zurück zu
denen auch shit zeit als wenn ja in die
eimer tempo tötet ich laufe ja geradezu
ina was früher kompliziert auf dem auf
dem weg ins los sein und so was alles
alter was macht ihr eigentlich die ganze
zeit darauf zu den hin
ich sammle meine leistung wieder auf und
getrunken voll schwer weil man dauernd
stofftier
ich laufe gerade angepfiffen
ja ich kenne hier sachen kkv alter ist
alles voll mit sachen von den sachen
holen ist nicht so voll soll er holt die
sachen packt die alle bei uns mit kisten
ja ich komme oder rappt sie weg nicht
weil ihr weil wir brauchen die wahl wir
haben auch voll wenig sachen eigentlich
nur noch gehabt sollten wir schon
versuchen zu behalten was immer geht
andrea sofort und verteidigung
jemand muss schon die sachen auf der
tristen für die ausrüstung hier hier
hier
ich habe aber nicht mal schwert hier gar
nicht im gähnend tus ascheberg ist was
ich habe das relativ viel dabei ich habe
ein schwert aber das reicht nicht
da macht es jetzt locker machen auf
angriff ich aber weiß ist es nicht gut
wenn wir alle rübergehen ich bleibe
lieber zu hause oder fahren lieber ein
inhaltlich bleibt zuhause bitte wird
dann gleich zu hause
dass die katze im dschungel nicht
ja das macht ist steht auch am besten
lässt wenn der henry einmal tag machen
könnte bitte da als hörster herz ich
könnte nicht sagen sondern ich habe
beide gekühlt bei der guide kommst du
dir könnte spotten stelle ich ihn
schnell
jetzt kommt schon wieder
die kommen zu uns schon weit gebracht
ich bin tor ich bin von zu hause etwas
schrecklich an
ich kann nichts machen wenn ich deinen
kommentar
gut gemacht so angepasst dass alles was
gemacht
ich dachte immer der umstieg schlechte
ich hab ja auch immer ich hab angst
gemacht gut gemacht ich habe die sachen
geholt da die caps zum beispiel aber
haben wir doch im groben guten punkt was
sie feuer und flamme ja da irgendwas gut
trainieren nicht mal die ganze zeit
sterben würde dann hätten jetzt was ihr
sterben würde bin ganz böser und falsch
wenn sie mal viel wer bist du egal wir
sind einfach alle beistand dann läuft
das ich werde jetzt hier noch kommt
natürlich weiß aber hier ist man mache
gerade den hat der meister verteidiger
und der refrain fährt okay ja ich mache
ganz böse sachen schützt die welt in
seinem leben oder so ich stelle mich
einfach davor die haben keine chance
sich ja so was ist denn die basis dass
das der ist dass der kloster und blogger
liegen die mannschaften solche sachen
ich etwas der closed und block in der
mitte oder was der dax lag noch die
sachen dann holst dir mach ich gift
rankweil und dann kommt er drüber ich
versuche jetzt irgendwelche bäume darauf
zu klettern und dann irgendwie von oben
das trifft ja nicht okay dürfen wir
dürfen uns eigentlich auch etwas abbauen
ja die dürfen alles abbauen
alles abbauen beim joker wird ihr so
bauen dass man da gar nicht mehr kommt
so leicht
der herr vorne gab es doch warum kommst
du jetzt mal ich bin aber nicht setzen
was einem blog besetzen
geologische sie hatte ich aber gefunden
die die r und natürlich darf die setzen
was an den sonst für unsinn
ja genau ich hab zwar nicht gelesen hat
kommt jetzt auch mal mit drüber ich bin
schon da ich schränke zu den rüber in
die base ich bin auch ich bin oben ja
okay machen doch angeführte muss jetzt
ablenken
ja ok schied von oben habe ich bin
gleich bei den basic mehr sachen als
clown und gebot machen und ich krieg
schaden 18 gäste mischten sich an die
parteibasis
der pass auf wenn er macht das alter der
bist schneller stärker als ich es
eigentlich hab ganz viel glück ist uns
besser
wie viel spielt was verloren
er hat noch kaputt gemacht leute wären
verloren
ja und das ding ist weg ich bin grad bei
den im chor gleich auch dann macht ihr
noch kaputt dann ist ja eine tolle den
droht kaputte nicht gewonnen nein
was sollen wir machen
alter mann diese scheiße ich hasse die
alle gestorben
ich mag es in rage kommt so das wars 3
weiterkämpfen okay okay lass mich mal
wieder drauf ich nehme jetzt nach und
sami awad jetzt was passiert habt ihr
noch mal alles besagt ja was machen wir
dann sagen wir haben hier passierte
herzlich freunde dann würde ich sagen
das war's mit
storm schittko ich weiß nicht keine
ahnung
mit ganz ganz starken gegner und wir
sind ja als micro pvp map wir haben
verkackt genauer zu leicht konnte man
gewinnen irgendwie kann es sein als man
hört dass man sofort alle sachen kampf
getötet es ist einfach ist aber wir
haben halt so ist das leben
wir haben verloren vielen dank bist du
schon rein bis zum nächsten mal und
maske jarvis